look at the way this man dressed is
impeccable suit line are you really
maybe I'll call it oh this old thing you
look fantastic and you're wearing two
sunglasses indoors at night that's an
incredible head she may be one of the
only people who can get away with doing
this I do a lot of time
yeah oh no it looks good I mean you're
getting away with it it's just okay yeah
okay we have put on glasses mmm these
are called take off glasses right yeah
like a lot of people wear glasses
because they can't see right these are
called take off glasses like a little
too much there yeah knowing that's not
looking as cool as you think it is how
are you good Hey I am fabulous ma'am and
traveling oh this big game yeah but the
game on Sunday
oh my gosh you were just I don't think
they know well they may not know you
were at the Super Bowl and you were at
Super Bowl media day
yes I was man Atlas here's the cool
thing very hard to do you got to ask Tom
Brady a question hey you know every year
do it from a fourth year in a row during
media day fabulous man for a football
fan this is like heaven yeah it's like
heaven with uniforms you don't say it's
like crazy
yeah this is Tom Brady you know we go
way back to SNL days when he's a he was
a host key host [ __ ] and you were a
writer you know so I always asked him a
good question like this time I asked him
I said hey man look you know on a scale
of 1 to 10 you a handsome guy right very
handsome guy yeah yeah what are we about
for us but for us before for what are
you talking about I'm a solid 5 so I
said hey Tom man you were handsome guy
you at least a 10 you know get a grip a
wife and all these good things going on
with you master hey if you could if you
could if you can give away two or three
of your handsome points would you give
him away
to be able to get back at the Giants
could the Giants beat you twice in the
Super Bowl I'm New York Giants yeah he
said I would give all my points
that's a competitor yeah so I said it's
cool so so you would give away some of
your Hanson points but maybe maybe
you'll show up at home with a chipped
tooth some bad hair got a little humping
your bad or something like that so
Giselle see she's cool with that you
know I mean yeah hey I betrayed her all
my points for another victory right he
said I was gonna ask that kind of people
yeah I'll bring it out that's fantastic
the person at home is wondering what
cookie would Bill Belichick wanna be you
want to know I really thought he was
safe in Newton that's an old old ass
cookie you don't say
he's old school I got a Fig Newton
what's wrong with a Fig Newton
according to tears too much money get in
the back teeth you got he picking them
out
Figg is an old-ass what are we talking
about Frank you're the only person I
know where I can ask you would you think
of the Super Bowl and within seconds
we're talking about Bill Belichick as a
Fig Newton corner and you're trying to
get him out of your back to take a quick
break Maura j.b smoove in a second
you